uh first of all great to see you uh i
really i really want to start with a big
thank you i la i watched all eight
episodes i laughed like a crazy person
um and i just want to thank you for
making me laugh so deeply
um
so i just want to start with that um and
also a huge thank you to peacock for
making the series right and yeah you
know um so for both of you uh not about
mcgruber my first question if someone
has actually never seen anything that
you've done before what is the first
thing you want them watching and why
wow that's a good one
um i'm gonna
gonna say
phoebe's playhouse yes
because
it only
it only sets the stage for this
i love that it sets the stage
brilliantly for this
i'm just going to selfishly say
like
three episodes of charmed
i mean it
okay
not the answers i was expecting
bro i love these answers this is great
um which of your friends and family were
actually the most excited when you told
them you got a role in mcgruber
um
my sister
lisa who adores the talent in this show
um
she was she understood you know joined
me at the end on this one was like oh
god heck yes you can't you know can i
visit it's like better
it was no no one knows i haven't told
anyone
can i have that answer
let me let me do it on a do-over that
was great
let's move on one of the things about
this series is that um it is unlike
anything else that's out there these
scripts are just in a world of their own
what is it like actually reading these
scripts for the first time and and
seeing what these guys want to put on
screen
not having been aware of mcgruber like i
had never seen the sketch
um i got the scripts and i and i got a
copy of the movie
so i watched this movie
and
it made me laugh out loud so hard
that i i couldn't say no i just i was
like this is absurd it's it's completely
ridiculous and yet
i'm laughing out loud and
on the page
it is funny but it's even funnier i mean
having seen episode one and two last
night at the premiere
it's it's genius so
yeah
that's yeah
i think
this
the reaction i had certainly when
reading it and definitely when watching
more so um was you wonder why it didn't
exist before in a weird way it felt so
necessary it felt so vital it's so punk
rock and so well placed and so
necessary for the times it's such a
tonic for the times that you're going oh
my god it's like it's a cool drink of
water where have you been right you want
something that riotous and bold and and
you just forget that
we can get away you know i command
peacock for having the you know
foresight and and cajones to put this
thing to take this
i
much-loved um
film and and really blow it out into
eight episodes where you can go just
deeper into all these characters these
absurd plot points and and just
luxuriate and all these wonderful
monologues of wills
you know
yes speaking speaking of will um one of
the things about him especially in this
series is just how fearless he is i mean
he is
going for it in a i mean this is a
really great performance just what he's
willing to put in what was it like
actually watching him work because i
mean he's naked in like half the
episodes he has to do all this i mean
i'm really impressed with his
performance agreed metaphorically and
literally and literally i mean he is um
so
sweet and
that sweetness and that innocence
that that magruber possesses
uh
is is really
a part of will
uh
and he exposes that in such a delightful
way
in in this character and in this epi in
all these episodes i mean it's
you know
it's great to work with somebody who's
that
open
and available and vulnerable it's just
amazing and brave yeah he is brave i
mean that was i i think one of the most
fearless actors to say the least you
know
complete conviction
and belief you know in
the emotional arc of the character but
brave enough to literally bear his soul
and his
and his took us what you know
[Laughter]
again i cannot express how hard i was
laughing last night watching the
episodes you know um uh what for both of
you guys what are you allowed to tease
about the actual season and who you play
i'm not sure what what what oh right
uh not a whole lot
um
but uh there are turns
there are turns coming some nice ones
too
you want to add
that was it that's what he's got
did you get there was the reason there
was a subtle nod
this guy so vulnerable
i am a fan of both of your uh both of
your work and i'm curious if you have
like a big scene on like a monday or say
like a big scene in mcgruber how early
on are you actually preparing for like a
big scene is it can you sort of take me
through like how you're getting ready
for
something that you know is going to be
challenging
breakfast uh
yeah
just
born ready
you don't want to come too front loaded
you want to know you want to hold on
obviously not let go yeah exactly you
got to be in the moment let things
happen yeah let things happen don't try
to make things happen you have to allow
them you do that that's the work
if you come in
too many ideas yeah get stuck in a rut
and get thrown yeah you don't want the
cement to set before you you know
have your lines all
there's about three more metaphors
[Laughter]
when when you were offered or when you
found out about the series how much did
that you get told about like the full
arc of your character what you'd be
doing and how much you know what i mean
like and how much was it sort of like
you want to be part of this they sent me
all eight
episodes fully written
and uh the film because i had not seen
the sketch
um
i looked at a few clips of sketch stuff
laughed
saw the movie
was in stitches
read the scripts and was like oh i'm in
i'm in this is this is
too goofy
you know
to say anything but yes
i'm
a big fan of the
of the film
um
saw the sketch after the film
and uh
was just you know on a plane immediately
you know
reading everything i couldn't wait to
come
uh lauren's an individual question for
you um as you probably know or have had
me i've talked to you before i am what
we call a large john wick fan um
yeah big john
um and so i'm curious what you can tease
about uh john wick four
which i know was basically like the
longest night shoot in existence
they shot oh
months and months of nights
i can tell you this
as a fan not just to somebody who's in
it but
um and this is based on reading the
script
it's going to be the best one yeah
awesome
can you tease any more than that
um
no
wish i could would that i could i would
but
no
um if it was the longest
string of night shoots of a film ever
made
no i don't know about that but there was
i think it was another film that i
vaguely remember
old movie i've been seven months six
weeks of nights we did
yeah
on apocalypse was it yeah we did we did
well we did well actually it was
i can't it was really long it might have
been
it might have been months
is it only from his canon that we're
measuring the uh right right
i can't i can't i got a rap but i uh i
know that they shot for months on wick
and it was literally all nights um which
is you know not awesome not easy on the
cast and crew um but but i gotta go uh i
just really want to say again thank you
i laughed so much i really want to thank
you for your work in the series i wish
you both nothing but the best thank you
thank you
you